[Aplausos]
[Música]
la energía nuclear es como el
entretenimiento para adultos poca gente
reconoce que le gusta pero luego te lo
encuentras en todas partes y da lo mismo
que la empresa que suministra
electricidad diga que la suya es 100%
renovable en la red eléctrica todos los
kilovatios son iguales
[Música]
así que sí amigos de visual políti por
si no eres conscientes os lo digo ahora
mismo es muy probable que estéis
consumiendo energía nuclear y ya sé lo
que estás pensando fonseca macho eres un
provocador no hay tantas centrales
nucleares en el mundo de hecho sólo hay
30 países con centrales nucleares es
decir que sólo uno de cada seis o siete
países en el mundo tiene reactores pero
esperad un momento porque hablando claro
no tienen las mismas necesidades
energéticas
vanuatu que china
[Música]
y hablamos de las principales economías
del mundo las agrupadas en el g20 sólo
hay 5 países sin nucleares y de esos 5
países turquía ya está construyendo su
primera central e italia importa un 10%
de su electricidad de las nucleares de
francia por lo tanto es un hecho las
principales economías del mundo utilizan
la energía nuclear y las economías
emergentes también lo tienen muy claro
en otros vídeos ya os hemos hablado del
crecimiento económico de china pues bien
hay tres indicadores que van de la mano
desde hace décadas crecimiento económico
más demanda energética y mayor
contaminación
[Música]
así que imaginaos por un momento las
industrias chinas necesitando cada vez
más energía a eso le podemos sumar la
migración de la población rural a las
ciudades pensadlo bien de repente
tenemos miles de oficinas fábricas
centros de ocio servicios y millones de
chinos encendiendo la luz a la vez
beijing shanghai y shenzhen son
megalópolis que hacen que madrid
caracas o washington parezcan un
pueblecito de los alpes así que ya os
podéis hacer una idea de toda la energía
que necesitan esto explica que china se
esté convirtiendo en la disneylandia de
las energías renovables no hace más que
instalar placas solares parques eólicos
y centrales hidroeléctricas año tras año
china lidera la inversión en renovables
y ya se lo que estáis pensando después
del incidente de fukushima en japón no
tendrán muchas ganas de construir
reactores nucleares verdad
[Música]
pues os equivocáis según datos del
organismo internacional de la energía
atómica en asia se construyen hoy día
más de la mitad de los reactores
nucleares que se están desarrollando en
el mundo
y cuántos son esos reactores nucleares
34 pues nada de eso son 27 en total
repartidos principalmente entre china
india y corea del sur en otras palabras
a pesar de fukushima la apuesta
energética de asia no se está limitando
a las renovables sino también a la
nuclear y diréis claro todo esto es
porque china es una dictadura que no
necesita escuchar a su pueblo verdad
pues nada más lejos de la realidad por
ejemplo el gobierno de taiwán que es
democrático sacó un referéndum para
cerrar sus centrales nucleares y que
dijeron los taiwaneses pues un rotundo
no incluso desde japón el país donde
ocurrió el incidente de fukushima nos
llegan noticias como esta
[Música]
un tribunal de japón rechazó una demanda
contra la construcción de una central
nuclear así que la pregunta es por qué
los países de asia insisten en instalar
centrales nucleares cuando hay otras
alternativas y también estaréis pensando
cuáles son las compañías que siguen
apostando por la nuclear y qué
tecnología utilizan hoy vamos a
responder a estas preguntas pero antes
vamos a ver un poco de historia
el dragón dormido os acordáis del dragón
smaug en el hobbit dormidos sobre
montañas de oro pues en la china de hace
50 años mao tse tung era ese dragón
dormido pero en lugar de oro y riquezas
lo que había era granos de arroz el país
era profundamente agrícola y permaneció
durante décadas en el subdesarrollo por
eso no debe extrañar que china llegara
más de 30 años a eso de la energía
nuclear hasta principios de los años 90
china no tenía ninguna central en 1990
sin ir más lejos el mix eléctrico de
china consistía en un 20% de
hidroeléctricas y un 80% de gas petróleo
y sobre todo carbón
en el año 2017 los combustibles fósiles
aún mantenían un peso del 71 por ciento
en su mix de generación eléctrica y ya
sabéis lo que eso significa carbón a
tope chinos con mascarillas y neblina en
las ciudades que prácticamente impide
ver el sol y parece que la cosa no va a
cambiar en el corto plazo al menos
después de ver noticias como esta de
septiembre de 2018
el boom de la construcción de plantas de
carbón en china provocó una alarma
climática pensadlo bien el único recurso
natural que tiene china es el carbón así
que no están dispuestos a renunciar a
ello mientras tanto la hidroeléctrica se
mantiene con un 19 por ciento y las
renovables suponen un 6% el 4% restante
y quedaos con este porcentaje el 4% lo
aportan los 40 reactores nucleares que
china ha construido en estos 27 últimos
años y que ya son más de los que operan
en rusia actualmente pero que ha pasado
para encontrarnos con estos datos pues
un dato que es francamente brutal la
demanda eléctrica en china se ha
multiplicado por 10 desde el año 1990
en otras palabras con todas las
centrales nucleares que se han
construido en china se suministraría la
mitad de la energía que el país
necesitaba en 1990 hoy tan solo es el 4%
el dragón dormido ha despertado y de qué
manera
[Música]
durán yo al dragón smaug le encantaba el
oro al dragón chino le encanta el uranio
ahora mismo china está construyendo 11
reactores más con una capacidad superior
a toda la potencia nuclear que tiene
actualmente el reino unido pero esperad
un momento porque tenéis que ver cuál es
la previsión para el año 2030
la agencia internacional de la energía
dice que china superará a estados unidos
como la mayor nación de energía nuclear
ya sé lo que estáis pensando todas estas
previsiones son después del tsunami de
2011 en japón ese tsunami que provocó el
accidente en la central nuclear de
fukushima todo una área devastada
cientos de miles de desplazados a aguas
contaminadas una catástrofe en
definitiva así que por qué seguir
invirtiendo en energía nuclear pues
básicamente se puede decir que hay un
elemento clave en la producción
energética que es que la electricidad no
puede almacenarse quizás en unos años
las baterías de litio den un salto
tecnológico y eliminen este
inconveniente pero a día de hoy es caro
inviable almacenar electricidad a gran
escala
y este es el principal problema de las
renovables las placas solares están muy
bien pero como producimos energía por la
noche además la base del sistema
eléctrico de china son las centrales
térmicas de carbón no necesitan
importarlo de otros países y como ya
hemos visto en otros vídeos
esto es todo un respiro pero no sólo eso
si hay una energía contaminante ese es
el carbón y por eso china tiene un
problema tan serio con la contaminación
así que la pregunta es si no podemos
usar carbón cuáles son las otras
alternativas que nos quedan una es la
producción eléctrica con gas natural
actualmente china importa un 40% del gas
que consume pero ya sabéis todos los
problemas políticos que tiene el gas si
recordáis en este otro vídeo os
contábamos lo caro que es comprar gas en
asia y eso explica noticias como esta
el spot del gas natural licuado en japón
alcanza en enero su máximo en tres años
china compite con japón por atraer a los
metaneros que circulan por el pacífico
lo que ha disparado los precios del gas
natural liquado ya que japón demanda
mucho más gas desde que paró sus
reactores nucleares tras fukushima por
lo tanto sólo queda una alternativa para
china energía nuclear es eficiente
funciona todo el día y por extraño que
parezca es bastante menos contaminante
que otras alternativas pero esperad un
momento porque no todo es tan sencillo
por un lado las centrales nucleares
necesitan de una tecnología que es muy
cara de instalar y además necesitan un
combustible el uranio que digamos que no
lo puedes encontrar en cualquier
gasolinera así que como lo está haciendo
china pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
made in china las falsificaciones chinas
son legendarias y si esto es lo que
estáis pensando que hizo china para
desarrollar su propia industria nuclear
pues copiar a los mejores sino trabajo
en sus inicios mano a mano con la
francesa frame atom la empresa estatal
conocida anteriormente como areva
también llegó a acuerdos con americana
westinghouse incluso algunos reactores
en china fueron desarrollados por la
compañía nuclear canadiense o la rusa
rosátom pero qué ocurrió a partir del
año 2000 pues que china exigió a las
empresas extranjeras la transferencia de
tecnología por ejemplo westinghouse tuvo
que permitir que los ingenieros chinos
pudieran aprender todos sus secretos
tecnológicos sólo así podían adaptar los
reactores a las condiciones chinas nadie
negocia contratos como los chinos así
que después de 10 años de trabajo la
tercera generación de reactores
nucleares made in china ya está aquí
[Música]
china se prepara para arrancar el primer
reactor nuclear ap1000 del mundo el
acuerdo que firmaron entonces preveía
que ahora china pudiera construir sus
propios reactores sin participación de
empresas extranjeras esta forma la
tecnología de las decenas de reactores
que china va a construir en sus próximos
años será cien por cien china además
aunque westinghouse quisiera expandir su
presencia en el mercado chino parece que
lo va a tener muy difícil tras noticias
como ésta
westinghouse podría verse afectada por
las nuevas restricciones de eeuu sobre
las exportaciones nucleares pero si hay
algo que no se puede copiar es el uranio
las centrales nucleares utilizan el
uranio como combustible y china carece
de este mineral en su territorio
[Música]
así que se han visto obligados a
importarlo pero los chinos también son
hábiles comerciantes y llevan años
moviéndose muy pero que muy bien
kazajistán produce el 40 por ciento del
uranio del mundo pues bien china ya
importa el 50 por ciento de su
producción también tiene acuerdos con
canadá y permanece atenta a las grandes
reservas de australia pero hay otros
países con lo que es mucho más sencillo
llegar a acuerdos comerciales
sin a comprar riotinto una mina de
uranio en namibia por 107 millones de
dólares
china gana terreno en níger para
conseguir el uranio que aumentará su
producción nuclear
[Música]
en definitiva el made in china se ha
extendido a la industria nuclear mundial
la joya de la corona de sus proyectos el
reactor o alone one ya se vende
internacionalmente y comenzará a operar
durante la próxima década en países como
argentina o pakistán y la empresa
estatal china también participa en la
construcción de un nuevo reactor nuclear
en reino unido pero eso es otra cuestión
para otro vídeo porque como ya os
habréis podido imaginar este es el
primer capítulo de una nueva serie de
vídeos que iremos sacando en visual
político una serie donde os explicaremos
todos los detalles de la energía nuclear
en el mundo si no os lo queréis perder
ya sabéis suscribiros a visual político
y darle a la campanita para no perderos
ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones
[Música]
mientras tanto hasta ahora la pregunta
es hasta donde pensáis que llegarán los
ambiciosos planes energéticos del dragón
chino creéis que la energía nuclear
seguirá creciendo en china o terminarán
cediendo su papel ante el empuje de las
energías renovables podéis dejarme
vuestra respuesta en los comentarios
y por supuesto no olvidéis visitar
nuestra página de patrón donde tendréis
acceso a contenido exclusivo si os ha
gustado este vídeo dadle a like
compartirlo con vuestros amigos y nos
vemos en el próximo un abrazo y hasta
pronto
[Música]